Today we'll be speaking with doctor Sherry Johnson,
a professor of psychology at the University of California Berkeley and the
director of the cow mania or comm program.
Dr. Johnson has conducted research on psychological facets of bipolar disorder
over the past 20 years.
Her work has been funded by the National Alliance for research on schizophrenia
and depression,
the National Institute of Mental Health,
the National Science Foundation and the National Cancer Institute.
She has published over 150 manuscripts including publications in leading
journals such as the Journal of Abnormal Psychology and the American Journal of
Psychiatry.
Dr. Johnson is also the co editor or coauthor of five books including emotion,
psychopathology,
and a best selling textbook on abnormal psychology.
She's also a fellow of the Association for Behavioral Medicine Research and the
American psychological society.
So now turn to a very special experts in emotion interview on emotion and
bipolar disorder with Doctor Sherry Johnson.
So welcome Sherry.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for having me,
Dan.
Well,
thank you.
So I thought what we could first start off is asking a bit about what got you
hooked or interested in emotion in the first place,
sort of where did it all begin for you?
Um,
well it started with a fascination was bipolar disorder and for me,
watching people as they went from there kind of baseline states into manic
states,
there's um,
so much emotionality about the manic states that it,
you can't help them be fast dated when you watch it.
Um,
and similarly as they go through the depression,
there's a lot of questions about what's happening with emotions during that
phase.
And so it really was just kind of one of those clinical experiences that drove
the question of,
okay,
how do we understand this from a research perspective?
Excellent.
So speaking of a research perspective than,
I wanted to ask you a few questions about your research in this domain.
So I mean,
you are widely known as this leading figure and trying to understand the nature
of emotional disturbance in bipolar disorder.
And I wonder if you could describe a little bit about your work that's looked
at,
um,
associations between heightened sensitivity to rewards and heightened goal
setting in this population?
Sure.
Um,
so I think that,
um,
what we've seen over the last 15 or so years is pretty consistent evidence that
people with bipolar disorder,
even when they're well,
um,
have this,
greater response rate or reactivity to the idea of an approaching reward or
having just received a reward.
Um,
so we think of that as elevated reward sensitivity.
You can see it even in people who haven't yet developed the diagnosis who just
have kind of minor symptoms and Lauren l his work has taken that further to say
it predicts onset.
So we think reward sensitivity is really related to the disorder.
The new,
I'm kind of,
I'm on is this idea that reward sensitivity is too broad.
It's just,
it's a huge part of your motivational system in the brain.
And I don't think all parts of broken in bipolar disorder.
So the question is,
what's really broken about this system?
Where is it disrupted in bipolar disorder and us?
So far?
I'm going to put my money on three pieces.
Um,
and that's not to say this is the whole kit and caboodle,
like we're still really trying to figure this out.
But three themes we've seen again and again.
Um,
the first is that people with bipolar disorder set much,
much more difficult goals for themselves and they'll pursue their goals even as
the going gets tough.
Um,
so one is high goal setting,
the other is and the,
and I'll say about a high goal setting,
it seems to be kind of there at baseline in the background.
It's not just a feature of the manic episodes.
Then there are other things that sort of seem to change in this state dependent
way as people are going through six s's and happy periods in their lives that
people with bipolar disorder,
we're relaxed,
spawn more intensively for a small shift and success are positive mood and two
areas where we see a lot of that kind of reactivity.
One is confidence.
So given us a small success that kind of leap upward into the million things
you,
they feel like they could conquer.
Um,
so that's really,
I think an important part of the puzzle because people then will take risks.
Um,
and then so related to confidence,
that upper bubble we're studying and you and I are studying this together.
So impulsivity,
um,
so becoming less guarded,
less careful about what you would do,
um,
being a little less cautious in the way you would think about situations.
And I think that's a big part we're seeing of kind of what happens with the
losses that people go through with them as they begin to get a little higher and
higher or doing things that later they really,
really regret.
So to recap,
the three parts of rewards setting that we're putting our money on right now,
it would be high goal setting confidence and impulsivity.
I mean,
it's so fascinating when you think of these three facets and it makes me wonder,
you know,
to what extent do you think they were late to predicting clinical course over
time?
I do in very different ways.
So high goal setting looks like it's got good sides and bad sides.
And that's probably true for all of us when we,
you know,
kind of have our interim questions,
right?
Our big dreams.
So being ambitious can spur great things.
People get mobilized to do things they wouldn't otherwise do.
They go after the big dreams that make a difference in life and in the world.
Um,
and so one of the things that we're excited about is we have some data we are
just writing up that says that those ambitions are a big part of the creativity
we see in bipolar disorder wanting more.
You know,
and more,
it's a,
it's a helpful thing,
but on the other hand it's also a predictor of,
um,
more severe course of mania over time.
Um,
so that's troubling.
The confidence and the impulsivity.
Those seem to relate a lot to the functional impairments we see in bipolar
disorder.
So I don't think that they have so much drive the symptoms as they do the kind
of,
um,
the mistakes people make when they get symptomatic that they later then feel
like,
oh,
I just lost this money,
or I just had trouble in relationship.
Right.
Just did something I really,
really regret.
So different strands taking us different directions,
um,
figuring it out.
Yeah.
And,
and what's really cool about what you're doing is you're not only documenting
these phenomena are these different facets.
You're also relating it to clinical course as you just spoke about.
And you've developed this really elegant and empirically validated treatment to
help individuals with bipolar disorder,
you know,
assisting them in managing and DNA intensifying these kind of overly positive
goal seeking states,
um,
which you focused on in your lab at UC Berkeley as part of the cow mania or comm
program.
And I wondered,
you know,
in this vein,
if you could tell us a little bit more about what are the essential therapeutic
ingredients of this intervention?
Because I think for many people,
the idea of trying to deintensify or calm down seems a bit counterintuitive,
right?
At first glance.
Yeah.
As in are we the killed Julie Team?
Um,
yeah.
so we're early on in gathering empirical data and I think that's going to be a
big part of the next 10 years.
Um,
but what we try to do as a multistep process,
first we try and just share what we know from research with people with bipolar
disorder.
Um,
and we don't assume that our model fits for everybody.
So we'll give measures and we'll do interviews to find out if if the person
we're working with has high goal setting or goes through spurts of confidence or
has these periods of impulsivity or get so really involved and kind of gold for
suits.
So we figure out which of these components they go through and they believe are
relevant for them.
The other thing we've learned over time is you can't just kind of wipe these
out.
These are often really valued parts of a person's identity.
Um,
and so we embed everything in a motivational interviewing perspective of helping
the person look at,
okay,
what's great about having those big dreams and goals for you,
but also where it is,
whereas it hurts you and what's the balance?
And only after looking at that balance,
do we think about,
is this something you want to moderate?
So far,
everyone we've taken through that process and sort of saying yes,
but it's not as linear.
She would think they're awesome parts of those dreams and ambitions and hopes
they really want to preserve and other parts they want to down regulate.
Mm.
Um,
so for any given module,
once we kind of have an agreement on is this an honored we want to try and
tackle,
then we'll come into behavioral strategies.
Um,
and what's fascinating is that a lot of times the person was bipolar disorder
will have some strategies that your sleeves,
so we start by gathering data on how well and when those work and then look for,
okay,
how do we need to supplement this or how do we need to add to this?
And what's happened for us is I feel like what we are as a kind of compendium of
all these great tools we're hearing from the people with bipolar disorder,
um,
because people develop their own idiosyncratic strategies for kind of down
regulating and we get to hear more and more and more of those.
And we're getting a longer and longer list of what people might do.
And try and how it works.
Um,
so it's again,
very driven by clinical observations against the kind of research.
I mean it's lovely.
It's like the perfect clinical science model,
right?
That by directional relationship between the science and the patient's right in
front of you.
We hope.
Yeah,
hope.
I mean at its best it's really fun to try and straddle between those two worlds.
Um,
for me,
I think a lot of the motivation for doing research is always kind of coming back
to this question of okay,
does it look like it's going to be helpful someday?
Um,
and when it is the referral,
when it isn't,
then we get to go back in and study a little harder and think a little harder.
So
do you think it's possible that these kinds of techniques could be applied to
individuals without a history of bipolar disorder?
Um,
that's a really fascinating question.
You and I,
I'm the academic communities are surrounded by hyper ambitious people who've
done well for being hyper ambitious,
um,
but often then also pay a cost.
And I think I'm kind of fascinated by go regulation in the general population.
I would love to study that more.
We're starting up a new study of intrapreneurs.
Um,
another place where,
you know,
startups in California,
it makes a huge difference to kind of have a big dream and a hope and an
ambition.
Um,
we don't,
we haven't been injured as far into that area in our research as I would like
to,
but I certainly think it's fascinating.
That's so interesting.
You'll have to keep us posted on what happens with the entrepreneurs.
Yeah.
I don't think many of us,
uh,
I don't think,
you know,
I mean,
it's a great example of for many of them,
they're not going to get one to downregulate.
Right,
right.
Um,
there are these adaptive qualities to reaching for the stars.
So,
no.
So the last thing I wanted to ask you is perhaps one of my most favorite things
to talk with you about,
which is some of the work we've done together since you've been such an amazing
mentor to me in this area.
And I've loved the work that we've gotten to do together.
And in the years that we've been trying to understand positive emotion and
bipolar disorder,
I mean,
when we've looked at the broad landscape of positive emotion,
that seems that not all positive emotions are elevated,
but it's a kind of a more nuanced profile,
right?
Like we're seeing heightened emotions are focused on the south,
like pride or reward,
you know,
like joy and enthusiasm.
And I just wondered,
you know,
how do you think that seeing that not all positive emotions are elevated,
but it's some and not others?
Um,
how does this change,
like the landscape of how we think about what bipolar disorder really is?
I think it's a fascinating question and I've loved the work.
I mean,
I really think you've spearheaded,
um,
uh,
kind of understanding of emotion and landscape more than,
than anybody has.
And the answers are really fun and interesting is this sense that it's,
um,
the joy they're experiencing is very tethered to making progress on a goal and
feeling like they're doing well in something.
So this sense of pride and euphoria,
but very,
I'm so focused.
And what's missing in that profile?
What's not as heightened,
um,
is the sense of other kinds of positive emotions versus like love and
connectedness.
Um,
I been fascinated by that because I think we might have tools at our disposal in
basic science to do something about that.
So to help people refocus on these other experiences of happiness.
So thinking about it,
your work and your kind of understanding this emotion to mean helps us think,
how do we help people gain better control in a way that's not about being a
killjoy?
It's not about taking away all forms of happiness,
it's about deemphasizing the happiness that's about your own self
accomplishments and appreciating more of the happy as that might be about the
small good moments in life.
I kind of mindful approach to appreciate and interpersonal connectedness,
nature,
other small calm.
I'm good moments.
Um,
so we,
I'm part of the collaborative team now that's looking at what could we do on
that front to help people with bipolar disorder rebalance.
So your collaborator in mind Juni Moscow.
It's is really spearheading a lot of this and I'm very excited to see how it
goes.
Yeah.
It makes me think too about some of these interventions we see that are focused
on promoting gratitude's.
So sort of these other focus,
positive feelings.
Might this be the kind of positivity you want to build while you're sort of,
you know,
calming or soothing at Vino attenuating other kinds of more self focused,
high arousal kinds of states.
Yeah.
Um,
I wonder about with all of this is how much is the issue,
you know,
can we help people frame the issue is not about being happy or joyful.
The issue is about being kind of hyper aroused and sell focused.
Um,
so right now,
um,
you know,
I'm working with this team of people to try and think.
How do you,
how do you develop the words and language to share that with the person who's
bipolar disorder to give them tools?
Um,
yeah,
I think there are clinical implications for open.
So I mean,
thinking about all the work you've done in bipolar disorder,
um,
both experimental work.
The clinical work and the intervention work.
When you look into the future horizon,
sort of,
where do you see the field headed?
Oh,
that's a great question.
I mean,
I think that you're a good example of future directions in that what you've done
is taken basic theory of what we're seeing at the surface and said,
how do we bring in more basic research tools to test this?
And that's what I think all of us need to be doing.
So how do we integrate this with neuroscience,
how we integrate this with psychophysiology,
um,
how do we bring it together with the work that's going on in kind of
neuroscience and psychiatry.
At the other end of the spectrum though,
I think that it raises a million questions about broader social context and the
culture.
And I mean,
isn't that kind of part of the fun thing about emotion science,
FX or science is that you get to spin and all those directions.
It's this great way branching from culture to subjective experience to
neuroscience.
Um,
and I think all of those paradigms need to be applied and considered for us to
really understand bipolar disorder.
So then when you have students approach you who are thinking about embarking in
this field,
the right emotion and mood disorders,
what advice do you have for them,
sort of where do you think they should set their sights as they look forward?
Well,
first I think they should come on in.
There's still a lot of questions and um,
I think it's an exciting area to be in with a lot of new discoveries and
technologies on the horizon.
I always think that for somebody entering the field,
perhaps the biggest goal is to find a question that they are in love with.
You know,
the kind of question that you wake up in the morning thinking I wonder if that
works like this.
And not to count on that coming from anywhere but sort of inside of them.
Um,
and that's hard.
It takes a certain amount of patients.
Like you might read things for a year or two that bore you don't say never.
Never.
I,
I've had those moments.
Um,
and so,
um,
having the patience to find something that just really makes your mind want to
tackle a question.
And then,
um,
not being afraid to find the collaborators and mentors they need to get the
skills to learn whatever technologies it's going to take.
Because I think our science is increasingly complex,
um,
and having kind of a hub of people that you count on together to brainstorm and
problem solve,
um,
is going to be,
I think,
the strategy of the future.
So that would be my advice.
But thank you so much,
Sherri,
for speaking with us today.
It's,
it's delightful to talk to you as always,
and good luck
series.
Thank you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Sherry Johnson
from the university,
California at Berkeley.